you don't expand by becoming someone  else you expand by becoming more of who  you are and I think this is important  because a lot of people who are trying  to like become influencers or trying to  create content they say I want to be  like him or I want to look like this or  I want to be that guy of my space but  the thing is it's like you don't want to  be the that guy of your space you just  want to be the you of your space because  at the end of the day people just  believe in authenticity and authenticity  is the alignment of three things it's  your thoughts your words and your  actions if what you truly believe is  what you are truly saying and you're  living in accordance with that you will  be authentic and the only way to do that  is to just be you